vous plaît arriver avant que cette belle
complicité s'installe entre diane lavoie
et sa fille il a fallu négocier avec la
colère persistante d'une orpheline
adopté dans le chaos
j'ai eu une petite accalmie chinois ce
que je voudrais leur histoire commence
en janvier 2010 melodyne se trouve parmi
ces orphelins entassés dans la cour
d'une crèche de port-au-prince pour leur
sécurité ils ne peuvent retourner dans
le bâtiment au québec les futurs parents
sont sans nouvelles depuis le séisme
c'était des moments très fade angoisses
des quêteux sais pas trop quoi qui se
passe lors et puis tu sais que ta fille
ella beau d'avoir vu et thé part au
prince je sais je sais dans quelle
condition que vivent les gens d'abord
notre équipe avait finalement retrouvé
ses enfants
premier à l'adoption même si peu de
tristesse qu'ils ont maintenant des
images qu'elle n'avait jamais vu en cela
réveille toutes sortes de souvenirs
j'étais probablement la moins préparée
de toute la gamme probablement celle
avec qui le lien n'avait pas été fait
j'avais pas été en haïti j'avais même
pas dit oui je le veux j'avais eu la
proposition le 4 janvier photo son nom
puis son argent
comme d'autres gouvernements ottawa et
québec organise une évacuation sans
précédent des enfants destinés à
l'adoption pour plusieurs familles cela
précipite un processus qui dure
normalement deux ou trois ans j'apprends
que les enfants arrivent durant la fin
de semaine et moins jeunes et ris je
n'ai pas l'ombre d'une chambre ou d'un
meuble généré je travaille encore je
sais rien à bord de vols nolisés et dans
des bras est connu 126 enfants vont
arriver de port au prince dans un froid
glacial
mais avant de rentrer dans leur nouvelle
maison il y à toutes les formalités
je l'avais d'un bref c'était comme un
peu elle-même éjecté j'ai fait mon
hockey ça va être compliqué ça a été un
petit peu plus compliqué mais j'ai vu
tout de suite à elle est lucide
parce que c'est pas te faire changer
comme ça de faire bouleversé ça ça rien
dit et piètre content ça se peut pas
sont arrivés vraiment dans des
conditions qui sont pas du tout optimale
pour accueillir un enfant on n'est pas
dans des situations vous les parents et
l'enfant sont en cocon on est en période
de crise le tremblement terre entraîné
une suspension de l'adoption en haïti
c'est ce qu'ils recommandent hélas par
la communauté internationale l'unicef de
qu'en période de crise on arrête tout
cette pause suscite une réflexion sur
l'adoption internationale
comme plusieurs pays l'ont fait
désormais haïti se conforme à la
convention de la haye le processus
centralisé et le consentement des
parents biologiques plus clairement
établie avant le séisme c'était je
dirais plus de gré à gré en des
orphelinats puis des organismes
d'adoption il ya maintenant une
accréditation des crèches fédé les
orphelins en haïti le nombre d'adoptions
internationales a fondu partout dans les
années 90 le québec adopté près de 1000
enfants par année dans divers pays
l'an dernier il n'y a eu que 139
adoptions internationales dont sept
dossiers seulement pour haïti souvient
pas de rien rien
parfois j'ai des choses fausses fois que
ça soit vrai
des trucs plus farfelues on peut je me
cache sur un chan à 13h aux ailiers
melodyne sont prêtes à en savoir plus
sur les circonstances exceptionnelles de
leur arrivée c'est important qu'on parle
du séisme parce que c'est ça ce qu'ils
ont à d'autres super cool c'est vrai un
homme et chose à parle des choses comme
bien des enfants adoptés melodyne
commencent à s'intéresser à ses origines
va peut-être retrouver mes parents à la
leur fils la voir dans un futur avec toi
j'ai vu était tout petit comme ceux en
attendant le manteau qui était trop
grand pour elle est devenue un précieux
souvenir
j'étais surprise et heureuse de savoir
que l'on va regarder ça parce que je
pensais que les avait jetés ici anne
louise despatie radio canada montréal